what up guys welcome to the just pearly
thanks YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts except I had a
smoothie today and but it's not actually
a smoothie it's like um
this company that
I was thinking about working with
and
they have
um
I don't know how they call it they want
me to do this like deal oh my gosh my
hair is so messy I'm sorry
I guess it's part of the brand according
to someone
now
what they want me to do is they want it
to be they had said the rock does this
like he owns part of a company I don't
know how it works but they saw my coffee
thoughts where I was saying that I like
the coffee in the morning but I put in
so much sugar that's just not good for
you
and that's why I haven't I still haven't
had coffee guys I was so close
I was so close
to Breaking that okay anyways
back to this so so
they sent me this um
powder right now at first I tried the
powder in water and I didn't like it too
much it's okay
then I tried it in milk
now it wasn't bad in water it just
didn't mix like maybe I need to mix it
better I don't know but and a little bit
of blueberries and this thing is amazing
it is so good
um
I don't know how to
I'm new to the drink industry okay
but I may come out with a smoothie line
I've always it's so funny I've always
wanted when I was a kid that was one of
my business ideas I've always been
industrious right and one of my ideas
was to have a smoothie shop
and maybe I will someday I want to drop
an album this year but I was like it'd
be cool to have okay and I'll tell you
why oh no oh no [__]
blessing I'm sorry I'm sorry blessing
it would be cool okay because smoothies
are so messy so I was trying to think of
a way that you could put together like
the drink make it less expensive I don't
know but
it makes smoothies affordable because
it's like you can either go get an eight
dollar smoothie from a store for a good
one and the real smoothie lovers
they know they know what's a real good
one
or you can make it at home but then the
blender's all messy and it's like
there's got to be a better way I haven't
thought of it but anyways sorry off
topic off topic
so
uh
I might be going into smoothies so guys
I'm going to talk about a problem when
you get bigger I have had so many coffee
thoughts okay I've had so many coffee
thoughts I've wanted to do
but
here's the issue that comes with it the
bigger you get
the more
oh sorry
it's not the uh
okay
um
just uh don't switch them today I guess
laughs
yeah
okay sorry guys
um
so so where was I talking about
oh okay the problem is the bigger you
get
I have stories but people start to watch
and what they'll pick apart your stories
and two they'll start to figure out who
they're about and I'm like no
no now are the majority of viewers gonna
do that well no not necessarily
but you don't really want to start a
drama where you're telling
one story right
and clearly all the good stories have a
little bit of drama in it you know like
what I'm gonna tell you I went to the
grocery store and it was uneventful no
but
I'm gonna tell you guys anyway all right
first of all first of all I have a lot
of thoughts
um
all right
I accidentally challenged Esther to a
fight I didn't mean to okay guys I have
been on Twitter oh speaking of Twitter
I'm trying to see I'm trying to gather
an email list to tell you guys about
events
and oh my gosh I got 19 emails all right
I have no emails and that's probably not
a good thing you're supposed to like get
your audience's emails and phone numbers
haven't done that so I'm gonna put the
link to that in the description give me
the info you don't have to give me the
your phone number if you don't want but
I was like we could do text updates for
events like whatever you want to give me
feel free because I want to do a red
pill boxing event and I also want to do
a million party but I'm probably gonna
be at 2 million by the time I put
together this million but I was thinking
we could start with
um such a scatter brain we could start
with the freaking like coffee shop
Meetup in London and I was like yeah we
can do like a text updates or whatever
so yeah sign up for that anyways anyways
so
I'm gonna tell you a couple stories I
accidentally challenged Esther to a
fight
now
how do you accidentally challenge
someone to a fight
you would think that would be all right
so if if you guys don't know Esther was
the girl that would not leave my podcast
at the end of the podcast like a month
ago
the other lady is this they're both nuts
absolutely nuts crazy women all right
like if I disappear tomorrow I look at
these two all right I'm just saying if I
had to put my anyways the other lady is
this I don't even know her name some
lady that came on my show and she showed
up in turtleneck and then I thought she
was a normal lady and then she
threatened my co-host and said I
disrespected her because I didn't let
her talk and say whatever she wanted and
give her mic time on a podcast I made
the entitlement of modern women can you
imagine paying a producer paying a staff
to set up a show and you know she's
probably gonna react to this too
because that's what they do with these
crazy lips but you know you just let
them let them go so so
you get
anyways so so she storms off threatens
me then so she didn't threaten me
whatever Esther came back to my
apartment at one in the morning
unannounced you know
crazy people right okay so
what's next security we have security
Now
it's a good investment you know
okay what was I talking about next
oh how did I accidentally challenge her
to a fight
so I was tweeted all right I have been
on the Twitter grind I have been on the
Twitter I have just been tweeting my
thoughts and it's crazy I'm almost at
100 000 followers I think I started out
at twenty thousand and I really wasn't
even looking to like
I mean you always want to grow on on
social medias but I was just tweeting
and then
I started oh my gosh she had even
funnier I started tweeting basic things
that I thought were just common sense
and I would just sit and laugh at how
the internet like I put strippers or
[__] because like literally what's it
I mean that used to be common knowledge
all right you know I didn't say you were
a bad person but we can't we can't act
like you're that sexually choosy if
you're letting guys pay fifty dollars to
see your boobs you can try to Rebrand
yourself and say you don't sleep with
all of them
fine fine but you may as well because
people are gonna assume that anyway look
it all right
and then they're gonna say oh Pearl's
too ugly she couldn't get a strip club
job anyway guys
you don't I come on you don't think I
could get a strip
all right you're right guys you're right
anyways
so I was just tweeting now what did I
tweet I tweeted something along the
lines of
oh I was tweeting about a red pill
boxing match all right and I was saying
I wanted to host a red pill boxing match
now imagine now here's the problem the
Liberals won't fight I've dm'd a bunch
of them A bunch of people that have been
talking [__] about me let's get in the
ring baby
and
they all
none of them would respond okay so as a
joke I said okay fine guys I'll fight
Esther
and I put laughing emojis I thought it
was clear that this was a joke I don't
know how that could be misconstrued is
not a joke
like I clearly don't want to see these
crazy ladies again they're obsessed with
me though
they're obsessed with me all I can say
is thanks for being a fan if you're
watching now anyways so so
then I find out people are screenshot
you know how it is on the internet
some people are screenshotting me or
story and she's like okay I'll fight you
now and I thought about I actually
genuinely thought about it I was like
well maybe we could do a boxing event
that'd be kind of funny
but I was like how is she gonna follow
the rules of a boxing event if she can't
follow the rules of a podcast I'm not
trying to play with someone that fights
dirty and maybe that's a badge of honor
I I know you guys there's people that
watch that do the street fighting thing
look it if I was gonna fight it was
gonna be a boxing match it's gonna be
with the ref without like I'm just I've
seen girls get no no no no no no no I'm
not gonna get my hair pulled I'm not
gonna get none of that
two two
I was like
I would have to do all the work I would
have to put up the money for the event
because clearly she's not making any
right I would have to I would give her
all the clout so I was like if I'm gonna
get into boxing event I need to get
someone that people actually know who
they are
I'm open to it though sign up for my
mailing list you know
maybe we'll see we'll see but I was
thinking there's all these beefs right
there's all these people that have beef
with each other I was like let's fight
it out with the ring in the ring and a
lot of the red pill guys said they would
do it or said maybe depending on who
they fight
lead attorney said he'd do it
sneako said he'd do it
um even Nick Fuentes said he would fight
destiny destiny
where I I'm offering you an in an invite
all right you can say you can say that
you are fighting conservatives literally
literally all right
but it's like the libs don't want to
fight now do I blame them for this or
too many emails I got
do I blame them for this not necessarily
right I mean
[__] what's the upside
this is the first time throwing the
event I don't even know if I'd make
money at it
I you know
so
yeah that's how I accidentally
challenged her to a fight now the second
thing I want to talk about there was a
bit of controversy
and I really really thought about if I
want to weigh in on this
because because guys
I just don't want to I don't want drama
with anyone I don't I don't want drama
but there was a certain content creator
and I know they're probably this is what
they do see you always think about
you'll say things and then you'll think
about how they're gonna pick apart
they're gonna be like a good story has
drama okay fine fine
but
I'm not interested
in like okay I've had a certain content
creator they just call me dumb okay well
if you think I'm dumb
um
I can't really like what am I gonna do
argue with you while I'm not dumb okay
well fine I'm an idiot bye like
oh actually I'm gonna
but this content creator had an issue
with another content creator
um because I went on I went on
um sauce cast and
I had an issue with them not paying so
saucecast
and I'm I'm only saying this because my
name was brought up all right sauce cast
has people that come in so when you're
in Miami sauce cast will offer to you to
come on the show basically people come
in and out of Miami all the time or
they're in Fort Lauderdale so it's like
45 minutes whatever
so saucecast has done a really good job
and if I was in Miami I would do goddamn
the same thing all right
of
when people are in town getting them on
the show
now
I have over a million subscribers all
right I had a hundred million views in
the month of December and I went on
slash cast now I agreed to do two weeks
of shows I did this completely free
now
some could say I should be mad that I
didn't charge and maybe they pay other
people I don't know
but
the way I look at it is I get to use
their Studio whenever I want
um I can pull clips for my channel and
genuinely I just like the show and I
would never accept a wage and do
something for free
um and then go on the internet and
complain later like that's just not and
it's hard because personally I just
think certain business things should
just stay behind the scenes and I also
don't think people realize how expensive
it is to set up a show
and I was really doing the math on their
Channel it was like 50
a show it was like 50 000 like I'm not a
show a month like they make
now their Studio probably costs like 10K
a month now if they pay
Natalie let's say they pay her 5K a
month they pay they have like two
producers they might pay 5K a month 10
20 25 and now Adam's the host
valutinement's the owner
so that leaves 25 Grand a month so let's
say
they pay Adam another five let's say
let's say they pay him 10 I don't know
five ten let's say let's say 10 let's
just give them 10. that's 35 Grand a
month now that means the owner Patrick
Bet Davis
is making fifteen thousand now you might
think that's okay well then you have to
pay your editors right and you know you
can tweak it and say it's twenty
thousand whatever then you got to pay
your editors then you got to pay the
people that clip it then you got to pay
for the thumbnails and I was just
thinking I'm like if they paid every
guest this person was asking for like
one grand or two grand
um and he was saying like why doesn't
they why don't they fly out my friends
I'm like honestly they're not going to
be taking home that much and just
because it's a big company like they
have a right to make money off of their
content this is just how I see it you
know you can disagree with me on that
but I really just did not appreciate
like
personally I'm never gonna complain
about a wage I accepted and
if I didn't like the wage that they gave
me I'm gonna renegotiate you know and
I've even been in situations where I've
gone on a podcast and I found out they
paid for someone smaller me now am I
gonna get mad at the podcast or am I
going to get mad at myself for not
asking for more money and I'm certainly
not gonna go on the internet and say oh
I wish you paid me more you know
it's just that's just not and but the
thing is I understand from another
person's point of view you look at
socialblade and you think oh they're
bringing home all this money like why
would they not pay their guests they're
not treating them right I really can
understand where where people are coming
from
but oh my gosh like last month guys the
expenses get so high oh not even to
factor in cleaning not even to factor in
like you know if you get like a cleaner
to come you know I'm and maybe you're
like oh the the staff can just pick up
after themselves really when does that
ever you know
um oh and they have the Jedediah
now look and you could argue but people
make the same argument with me they're
like why like you should pay for this
this and this like a lot of times guests
will be like oh will you pay me this
much money to come on and I'm like
and the reason is because if I pay one
guest then word gets around then you got
to pay all the guests and those expenses
add up guys
like we're just trying to run a show
here and I think a lot of times on the
outside looking in you just think
they're taking home all this dough
and oh and we didn't even factor in
equipment guys
yeah and that's the thing people don't
like their studio saucecast is a nice
Studio
it is a nice Studio I can bet they
probably paid over A month's ad Revenue
I've certainly paid over A month's ad
revenue for my studio
so and they have multiple Studios so I'm
just thinking
and they had to buy all their Furniture
mine came with this place
so it's just like expense expense add up
and you could argue but and then they
would argue oh well it's a big company
and they should be able to take money
um out of the other company for like
that basically to subsidize like they
said oh well Patrick has a big house you
know and I'm just thinking like well I
mean you could argue my parents have a
lot of money so maybe I they should just
pay for my studio right and my guess
because my parents have a lot of money
and
what is Patrick but David worth I'm just
gonna look this up but the thing is as a
business person like you're always
looking to see if it's profitable so if
Patrick Bet Davis and let's say so let's
see but Davis no net worth let's say
he's worth
I mean I'm sure he's worth a [__] ton of
money
um
it doesn't even say all right
wow that's a lot of money 200 million
um wow wow that's a lot of money but say
he's worth that much he he's going to be
putting money into this project right
and he has to look to see if it's
profitable and now to a man
making 200 million he's like
which I I doubt all that's cash it's
probably
partially in the company or whatever but
whatever he's gonna look at
how much that business is making and
he's like I'm only bringing in 10k a
month from this [__]
oh and now they want me to pay yes and
at 2K a guest oh well now I'm making 5K
now he's doing charity work and nobody
wants to do charity work so look I just
wanted to give that insight
um
because a lot of people they just won't
understand that that's that's the second
thing
see and even saying this all right
I'm nervous because I don't I don't want
drama I don't want drama but you know I
just that that is my that is my thing
all right now
freaking
third third thing third thing
Nick Fuentes
laughs
guys I understand why some of you
wouldn't want me to have them on
and I understand that some of y'all
wanted me to do more research or
whatever and like No And
seeing where you're coming from but I
just when I bring guests on I really
like to have an open conversation I
don't like to have too many preconceived
notions about them and I like to give
them a chance to speak because in my
head okay we'll have the first
conversation and if there's stuff missed
we can do another and we can do another
you know I'm new in the content game
there's always more and
if you believe that you shouldn't give
platforms to certain people that's fine
I understand that belief personally
I don't believe it I believe in freedom
of speech I believe you should put
everyone with the worst ideas on one
panel okay I would put a BLM supporter
a white supremacist
a I mean we would have security all
right we would have we would certainly
have security
um
I don't know everyone on the opposite
ends
to talk about a topic I just I just
believe in freedom of speech so
you know
take that with a grain of salt take it
or leave it
um what else has been going on yeah and
that's why it's been crazy lately
because last month we had Destiny come
in and so we're doing all this content
with Destiny then we had Nick Fuentes
last week doing all this content with
Nick next month is going to be
um
Melanie King is Coming
um MTR is coming and maybe
uh Maggie this lady is going to do a
wife School episode with me is coming
and maybe one or two more
we're also thinking about doing a
cooking channel
yeah so
I'm not a cooking channel sorry a
fitness channel I was trying to think of
the stuff I already do and I was like I
already do it every day maybe I should
just figure out a way to film it you
know what I mean I don't want my whole
life filmed but I'm like I was thinking
about getting into yoga so I was like we
could do a yoga Journey Channel but I
was thinking it should be on a separate
Channel
I'm just thinking
another thing another thing so a lot of
times people will ask me
why I do what I do right and I when I
say entertainment people people look at
this as a if it's like a bad thing I'm
like guys you can't be on YouTube if
you're not entertaining
entertainment always always has to be
first and you guys can disagree with
that but your favorite teachers were not
the most educated one they were the most
entertaining and if you guys don't focus
on the entertainment
like No One's Gonna watch it's like
watch time that's the most important
metric that YouTube uses
um you can be educational and
entertaining you can do both but
so
I guess I gotta go with that
entertainment
oh but a lot of people ask me and I'm
putting this at the end of this coffee
thought because
it's a bit personal and I try not to say
this on like a ton of podcasts but one
thing that like men's Centric content
has done
is it really made me understand I had a
close relative
um a couple years ago he he tried to
commit suicide and it was over a girl
and I really didn't
um
understand it like I really didn't
understand it I thought it was like the
dumb I'm like why would you
and
watching red pill content
um
one made me appreciate the men in my
life more and two made me understand
that family member
um
and I think that women should really
listen we should listen to men to
understand where they're coming from
because it helps us to have better
relationships with them and it helps the
men because we can be you know try to
get along with them better
um and so
so yeah that's that's partially
what
I don't want to say like
that's definitely not why I started the
whole Channel but it's what made men's
Centric content resonate with me because
I just really
I don't know I just started to
understand like what happened because
for a lot of years like I didn't
um
yeah so
anyways guys this is my coffee talk
um you know
take it or leave it
ah I get so nervous I just don't I don't
want
yeah
that's oh my gosh that's the other thing
is the bigger you get the more people
will just they're so ready to like fight
with you because because it becomes
profitable for them to fight with you so
they'll just start nitpicking everything
you say they'll start
doing all this stuff and it's because
it's because they want to make money and
gain subs off of fighting with you
sometimes they just don't like you I'm
not even gonna lie sometimes that is too
but other times it's just like yeah yeah
so anyways take that with a grain of
salt that's my coffee thought for them
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time